depuis la dernière élection
présidentielle américaine la russie a
été plus souvent qu'autrement associé à
la désinformation mais au-delà de cette
incursion russe dans le contexte
américain ci est à travers des médias
tels que rds pique nique que moscou
exerce son influence en plusieurs
langues et sur plusieurs territoires
la journaliste les orale a été à
l'emploi de rt est ce qu'elle a vu de
l'intérieur l'a poussé à démissionner en
direct
de
la russie un bras si on veut de
propagande à l'échelle internationale
incarnée par spoutnik et rtc
dans le fond c'est pas clandestins comme
l'ingérence politique c'est vraiment
ouvert donc on quand on lit un article
de russia today ou de spoutnik on est
censé savoir que le ccd médias qui sont
financés par le gouvernement là où il
s'est un peu moins clair ces médias lors
mis sur pied des gens de médias viraux
pour essayer d'atteindre les jeunes dont
des pages facebook et twitter qui
s'appelle india ou une question mystère
ou c'est pas tout à fait clair que c'est
lié aux grands plus ne sait vraiment se
présenter comme des vidéos virales style
beaux speed mais c'est clairement s'ils
sont opérés par
s'est vraiment fait pour essayer
d'atteindre un autre tour un peu plus
jeunes mais là encore ça suit les mêmes
l'historial
marché
à chacun
quelle mesure tu parlais du financement
des organes de presse la parler le
pouvoir central en russie dans quelle
mesure les liens que le kremlin se sont
rapprochés spots mais qui a été créée
par le fils de communication
internationale marius carrément recettes
des financements de dollars us n'a été
créé par l'ancien porte parole du
président vladimir poutine donc les deux
affirment qu'ils sont complètement
dépendants mais quand on regarde leur
couverture vont jamais jamais m
sahling toujours avec les intérêts de la
russie
les histoires qui vont sortir vont
souvent collé aux intérêts nationaux de
la russie la cdpm les ennemis de la
russie comme si leur société
s'effondraient comme ça allait mal donc
je savais exactement donc on joue sur
des clivages sociaux qui existent déjà
et qui sont là par exemple racheter des
hispaniques ont fait une couverture
vraiment de me rameurs des
manifestations du jeu les gens par
exemple pour montrer comment ça va pas
bien en france comment les gens sont pas
d'accord comment la société tente de se
quitter la boîte